a pesar de las fracturas la extrema
derecha ha logrado abrirse un espacio
considerable en el electorado francés la
pugna es entre la candidata de la
agrupación nacional marine le pen y el
representante de reconquista edic se me
llega con un voto dividido
porque entre ambos se pueden estar
contrarrestando y no el epen por un lado
sigue por delante en lo que sería el
voto obrero el voto de la clase
trabajadora mientras que ese muro está
haciendo más hincapié en lo que es la
clase acomodada y los electores de ese
género con el antiguo legalismo dependen
alrededor del 22 por ciento de los votos
mientras que se mojó un 85 entre los dos
superan el 27 por ciento de los votos
que obtendría el actual mandatario
enmanuel macrón en primera vuelta según
la encuesta ipsos ofra desencantados
inconformes con el gobierno de macrón
patriotas y antisistemas son algunos de
los electores que se decantan por la
extrema derecha pero su discurso también
ha calado en parte de la juventud
principalmente porque ha servido a entre
otras entre otras cosas utilizadas muy
bien las redes sociales cosas izquierda
no se ha sabido adaptar a ello además de
tener la juventud que tiene ciertos
problemas
y en la derecha o la extrema derecha en
este caso le ofrecen soluciones
simplistas las banderas compartidas
entre los dos candidatos son muchas la
anti migración el orden la seguridad la
protección de los valores tradicionales
entre otras pero aun así intentan
distanciarse de moore de 63 años se
vendía como la novedad con una campaña
marcada por apelar a la emotividad y
exacerbando el discurso de la extrema
derecha sobre todo en temas de migración
proponiendo un ministerio encargado de
devolver a miles de personas a su país
somos los únicos herederos de la derecha
que amamos a francia a la gente al
trabajo al orden ya la identidad
depp en una cara conocida ha intentado
suavizar su imagen haciendo una campaña
más cercana a la gente concentrándose en
problemáticas concretas
contra el bloque de las élites contra la
oligarquía que encarna emanuel ma con
ésta el pueblo y el pueblo es más
numeroso que la casta a pesar de que
para muchos el discurso del epen estaba
desgastado las encuestas indican que se
enfrentaría a su antiguo rival en manual
macrón en una segunda vuelta
[Aplausos]